I find myself thinking about it almost
every day I am so incredibly lucky to
have experienced this has definitely
changed a lot of how I think and how I
act I'm 17 and I'm in high school so you
know the obvious questions that are on
my mind is you know what school do I
want to go to what do I want to study
what am I gonna be doing for the rest of
my life it's a little bit daunting you
don't exactly know what you want to do
or how you want to do it and you know
exactly what life holds in the cards for
you
I mean sure it'd be cool if you knew
exactly what you're gonna do but you
know then where's the adventure in that
and I'm just kind of waiting to see
what's going to happen and then how
you're gonna react to it because that's
really all you can control is how you're
going to navigate things
going down a river is kind of like an
allegory for life like you don't you
don't know what's around that next bend
you don't know what's going to happen
all you can control is how you're
reacting with everything
when you first start in the Grand Canyon
you're kind of overwhelmed by just the
natural beauty and just being completely
emerged in this immense thing it's just
getting kids out of their comfort zone
and exposing them to new experiences and
new people and it's that magic that
happens on a trip where you become a
family it's not for at-risk youth it's
not for wealthy youth it's for any youth
because any youth can benefit from a
river trip that's the goal is how do we
inspire curiosity about the place and
about each other I'm scraping the sand
and algae off
the question was asked when we first
started doing this about ten years ago
you know can kids do quality data
collection that is useful to scientists
they've got the special opportunity to
take part in science in this new place
that they're discovering this kind of
made me realize that everything depends
on really little things like tiny little
bugs and control of the whole fish
population of a river you start to ask
questions about one thing how is that
connected to another insect how is that
connected to the birds or the fish or
the bats
it's an exposure to science in a
positive way and those opportunities are
more and more rare for our youth and not
that every kid on this trip is gonna go
out there and be a scientist but every
kid on one of these trips is going to
have a sense of awareness of the place
and what's here and what goes on here
and they're gonna take that with them
gcy is really helping kids truly
understand how exactly all of this works
and what we can do to help it it kind of
boosts your confidence to go around in
your own community and kind of figure
out what you can do to help things
they're being on the gcy trip just kind
of created this awareness for me from
like where our water comes from the
Colorado River the water gets pumped you
know all over the country to feed a lot
of different communities and I have this
giant reservoir in my backyard so where
does that water go then how am I using
it
so I think that sort of sense of
adventure kind of made me want to
discover it made me want to learn more
about the world that I live in
and I think I'm a lot more conscious now
because of it when I see a river I don't
just see water I see an entire ecosystem
once you kind of gain that knowledge
that whatever water you're using you
know in your community is water that's
not going into that ecosystem you become
I become a lot more conscious of how I'm
using butter but just how amazing it was
in those moments that I had where I was
really able to reflect and kind of find
pieces of myself in the canyon those
moments are so important to me and I
never want to lose those kind of moments
so I know that no matter where I am in
my life what I'm doing how I'm doing it
I will be seeking out those
opportunities to experience those
moments
you